here is a spring a weight rather
attached to a spring and it's suspended
from a ceiling okay now this is an
interesting situation to us because if I
have it there just at rest okay if I
actually pick up this way and lift it up
a little bit right so the spring is no
longer stretched out all the way if I
hold it out there and then drop it what
would you don't shout out to [ __ ] just
think about protecting what would you
predict will happen I've lifted it up
right so that it's above it where it's
normal happy state is and I'll just let
go what do you predict it too so I want
to have a crack we reckon okay so the
first thing is going to happen is
because I've lifted it up I've resisted
gravity so I'll put it in an unnatural
spot and then of course it's going to
drop as soon as I release right but it's
not going to drop forever assuming the
spring holds okay it's going to go down
and like a bungee jumper it's going to
come back up right but it's not going to
come back up forever obviously
eventually at some point its upward
velocity is overcome by gravity which
accelerates it back down so your game is
kind of up and down with them okay so we
can model this in a really simple way
I'm not gonna worry about all the
different air resistance and blah blah
blah my question just gives us this okay
that's that's the only starting point
gets all the information you have I
think let me just check yes um and I'm
going to lift it up so that it's two
meters above its starting point 2 meters
about starting point okay so let's call
all of these use in meters and these are
the questions that they want us to try
and unpack right using this result we've
just develop can yet be square as a
function of displacement can you find
out where else it's at rest that word
else is important we'll get to in a
second hey can you work out what the
next move speed is okay so if I picked
it up I've lifted at 2 meters above I
need a coordinate system on here because
I don't have anything to describe what
is going on what would you like me to do
wait okay so where it is right now let's
call that displacement 0 okay so that
means I've now got this imagined access
happening here it's an x-axis this is my
displacement and I'm going to call that
I'm Peter suggested go call that zero I
don't have to call that zero if I wanted
to I could call this zero or I can call
the 40 whatever I like what else
conveniently now this number is
convenient to me why is that but why
make that zero why I think that horse
race between ah very good remember we
said it's gone up and down up and down
all right it's not just going up and
down it's going a particular kind of up
and down what kind of up and down is
this this is simple harmonic motion
isn't this is minus n square where n is
2 x okay so therefore it makes sense if
I can just like perform we saw off we
can eliminate the phase the plus alpha
that makes numbers nice well if I can
eliminate the constant at the front
that's all so nice right so this is just
regular simple harmonic motion cool okay
so what I'm going to do set that to zero
right you might like to say let the
objects resting point B X equal 0
done ok so now I've defined a current
system and that's not a given by the way
you have you often have to define it for
yourself now i'm going to use this
result this one's here ok the reason i
know to use this is just like before
when i saw unlock velocity i Function a
displacement acceleration function just
by smell right so this is what connects
this is the only tool i have to access
because otherwise i'm all in terms of
teas right there's no time the situation
whatsoever ok so I'm going to say since
that's X double dot that is d of half V
squared or 3x and that's negative 4 ok
right now wherever I go from here look
apart a look at what's aiming for what
do I do I'm going to integrate with
respect to X ok I want me to point out
in extension one this is the one of the
hardest things once you've got all this
motions the flyer in your hand what do
you choose to differentiate with respect
to just look carefully and what
variables you have okay I'm gonna
integrate both sides with respect to X
that leaves me with half V squared on
the left hand side what's the primitive
function of leave before X terms ok now
I'm not quite finished yet this is my
definite integral right so there's a
constant flying around just by
convention I mean normally I would write
plus C here ok but in a second I have to
double this do you see I have to
download right so just by convention I'm
gonna say a half suit ok because if
Caesar constant half see is also a
constant so I'm just going to say that
ok the only reason I've done that so
that now when I double at answer the
first part of the question x 2 x 2 x 2
and I just have a simple number no
fractions involved ok or no adult good
ok answered that pop a question now
where can I move on what can I do with
this what can I do with this because i'm
actually not finished yet this constant
i can deal with right when teasing
and the objects out of grass list okay
now i am going to start with an initial
condition but it's actually not going to
have anything to do with time right even
if I'm calling an initial collision T
equals zero I have nowhere to put in T
equals zero I've got no teeth to
substitute this into okay so instead I
want to know something about the
displacement okay I want to do something
about where the weight is situation and
therefore what is happening okay so for
example remember i said i was going to
lift this thing up how much higher than
where it started two meters so this
thing is going to go up to here and i'm
going to put it to okay so this is where
it starts i'm not going to bother st.
equal zero because i've got no taste of
subsidy to but i can say rather than
when or where where the essay they
displaced it where I am is x equals 2
what's the velocity at that point you
can know it's 0 for two reasons number
one simple harmonic motion it has to be
0 at its extremities okay but number two
what was I doing when I dropped for me
it was still at that point right and
then I dropped it so where am I there
I'm not moving so i can say where x
equals to V equals and i'm going to
substitute as usual so I'm going to say
negative 4 times for that okay straight
substitution so what's my closet you
trust it so now I've answered part a now
I have an expression for V squared in
terms of displacement
I'll just write the 16 of fun that my
bonita okay so far so good